this was the day after Donald Trump took
office exactly three years on he no
faces a trial in the US Senate which
could make that a reality
it's an historic moment and it started
in July last year with what should have
been a routine phone call from his desk
in the Oval Office Donald Trump called
the president of Ukraine a whistleblower
was worried about what they had about
the phone call and filed a complaint and
that alerted Congress the allegation
President Trump was holding back
hundreds of millions of dollars in
military aid meant for Ukraine and it
would be sent if the Ukrainian president
announced an investigation into Trump's
political rival former Vice President
Joe Biden and his son hunter who worked
in Ukraine Donald Trump didn't
understand the fuss I made a call the
call was perfect he released the
transcript but it seemed to cause more
trouble the key section as the Ukrainian
president promises to buy more US
missiles
Trump responds I would like you to do as
a favor though he asks for
investigations into a debunked
conspiracy theory about the election and
later brings up the Biden's asking for
help from foreign governments that could
impact US elections is against the law
the president must be held accountable
no one is above the law the Democrats
who controlled the House of
Representatives announced an impeachment
inquiry would begin the White House
refused to cooperate several career
diplomats came forward anyway they
testified under oath what the
whistleblower said was true Colonel
Alexander Whitman was on the call he
later reported it to White House lawyers
it is improper for the President of the
United States to demand a foreign
government investigate a US citizen and
a political opponent the former US
ambassador testified that she was
removed from her position after the
president's personal lawyer Rudy
Giuliani pushed to get her removed
Ukrainians who prefer to play by the old
corrupt rules sought to remove me what
continues to amaze me is that they found
Americans willing to partner with them
and working together they apparently
succeeded in orchestrating the removal
of a US ambassador
others said a small group of people
close to the president were running a
kind of shadow back-channel US policy in
Ukraine it became clear to me that
Giuliani's efforts to gin up politically
motivated investigations we're now
infecting u.s. engagement with Ukraine
leveraging president solinsky's desire
for a White House meeting
then came testimony from ambassador
Gordon Sunland he told Congress the new
Ukrainian president wanted a White House
meeting and he knew what he had to do to
get it investigate the Biden's was there
a quid pro quo as I testified previously
with regard to the requested White House
call and the White House meeting the
answer is yes Sunderland was a million
dollar donor to the president's
inauguration he was rewarded with the
job of ambassador to the European Union
he was a key player with Ukraine and
insisted senior figures knew what was
going on everyone was in the loop the
suggestion that we were engaged in some
irregular or rogue diplomacy is
absolutely false the Democrats have
delivered two articles of impeachment
one for abuse of power the second for
obstruction of Congress two key facts
have not changed that are critical to
these impeachment proceedings one
Ukraine in fact received the aid and two
there was no investigation into the
Biden's throat at all President Trump
insists he did nothing wrong we're
achieving what no administration has
ever achieved before and what do I get
out of it tell me I get impeached that's
what I get at it
by these radical left lunatics I get
impeached do you solemnly swear no the
Senate has been sworn in to act as a one
hundred strong jury in the trial of
President Trump this is only the third
presidential impeachment trial in
American history when the trial gets
underway there may be witnesses there
may be new evidence there will be votes
on that there will be long days and
the end it will take 2/3 of the Senate
to vote to convict a president and
remove them from office Allen Fisher al
Jazeera Washington
[Music]